I have everyone's attention please
okay you know you kid won the goldfish
in that little baggie from the school
fair and you didn't want that nasty
thing in your house so you push it down
the toilet
well this way I'm into old Pharisees I
can only imagine how you feel I promised
you the secrets of the universe nothing
more so there's some secrets out there
that the universe don't know about
okay okay there is no K he's been dead
for over 40 years
what somehow history has been rewritten
there has to be a reason this is
happening and K seems to be at the
center of it you're gonna send me back
to 1969 first we gotta get high my man
for real no I mean really high all you
gotta do is jump you've got 24 hours
after that there is no coming back
okay how do you know my name number
agent a men in black but I'm from the
future we're partners good future man
where to first of all I mean even my
parents no no space gun is there anybody
here who's not an alien
we have a minute okay trying to blow my
cover
whoa Andy Warhol is one of us who's the
dumbass whoa
you know I don't know problem pimp-slap
in the shiznit out of Andy Warhol why
get these in the future that's what I'm
talking about
we're running out of time we're running
out of clues and there's an invasion
coming so really we need to go right now
Nora
hey how old are you 29 we've got some
city miles on you